Debra's in Connecticut hi Debra welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank you -
for your time today
absolutely keeping your time what can
Doctor John answer for you today so I've
been married for six years and my
husband was one of my best friends for
the six years prior to that three months
ago I came home from work if I has been
waiting for me he was all packed up and
she told me he was leaving it completely
blindsided me as we hadn't been fighting
or in counseling or even discussed
counseling or anything
now we're in the divorce process and he
says he does not want to work for us so
now I'm grieving over the loss of my
relationship and the life I thought we
were going to have and I'm just trying
to figure out where I go from here that
sucks I'm so sorry thank you because you
lost man you lost history right you lost
a decade plus the best friend plus the
decades ahead you said that well I'm
heartbroken for you thank you how long
ago do you leave I was three months ago
was the 17th of February because we've
just gone back from our 6-year
anniversary weekend away just packed up
and took off huh yeah he was all for
President's Day and I had a bit of work
when I came home he was just waiting to
tell me he was leaving so a couple of
things you use the word grief and that's
a word that's been rile around in my
head recently I even went and got a
couple of books on it and talked to a
couple of colleagues who are experts on
grief and I think that's something
that's in the water in the air that
we're all wrestling with right now I
also think as a collective culture we
are terrible at grieving you get a
couple days off of work or your buddies
have your friends already told you to
start saying like well you're gonna
start they started giving you dumb
advice yet yeah so I want to give you
permission for a few things and then I
want to hear what grandpa Dave has to
say his may involve a shotgun more than
mine does but number one there is no
right way to grieve everybody does it
differently and so everyone's you're
gonna get stupid advice that's gonna be
coming from people's hearts gonna be
trying to help and it's gonna be more
hurtful than if they had just said
nothing the second thing that's super
important is you cannot grieve alone and
this is particularly hard for you right
now because your best friends the one
that hosts you right how are you yeah I
just turned 30
so you're gonna have to do the hard hard
thing and reach out to other friends and
be vulnerable again okay are you in a in
a good church by chance yeah that's
number three no I'm not I just moved to
my area and we had just literally
purchased a condo in December I would
really love if you could find if you're
30 a 45 or 50 year old lady who is wise
and has has some miles has been through
some stuff maybe even something similar
and spent a little time with her because
she's her life is where you're gonna be
mm-hmm and it'll help you to realize
this is not the end of the world because
you can see her over here she's
successful she's remarried she's got
kids she's whatever after the first one
that crashed and and you know like a
living example of hope about what your
future serve what small picture of what
your tomorrow probably actually is but
it helps so it helps to have that in
front of you and go yeah that's that's
not only what I want but her standing
here makes me believe I can do it that
kind of a thing I just love for you to
find that person that's why I asked you
about Church not to shame you about
Church but just to say if there was a
cool lady at the church even if you
didn't know her that well if you just
saw her across the room and you thought
now he's thought she's a kind of got it
put together you know I want to talk to
her and call her and ask her if you
could just have a cup of coffee and go I
just you know I need a little lady a
decade or two ahead of me here that can
show me that that I'm gonna live through
this and that this is when I look back
on this in ten years it's not gonna feel
like it feels today it's gonna feel
healed and always be some sadness about
it always looking back but it's not
going to ruin your life there'll be a
scar it won't be bleeding anymore though
yeah right yeah it doesn't ruin your
life
and so something like that I'll never
forget one time in a Financial Peace
University class way back when we very
first started doing them I was in the
small group that's how long ago okay I'm
leading the small group and this lady
was sitting there and she was in her 20s
and she's crying and she's cuts hair for
a living and she's raising a kid and
she's like oh I'm never up he broke my
whole life I'll never be able to you
know and you know it's tears run down
her face I cannot believe I'll ever be
able to win and I God just put on the
other side of the room in that same
group of 52 year old lady she said yeah
when I was your age I was you by the way
I own three shops now and I've got seven
or $50,000 and mutual funds
so you're you'll be okay hmm who's like
I feature you sitting here you know and
all of a sudden the lady just you know
the tears stopped instantly and she kind
of went way all right it didn't make the
pain go away
didn't make the hurt go away in case it
was hopelessness and fear you know she
was afraid of the current situation and
hopeless about the future but there sat
her future the future version of her
sitting across the room the God just
positioned in that same small group and
as magical it's very cool
Holly if all of us could look across be
that person to sit across the
metaphorical circle this she doesn't
need advice she just needs someone to
say it's gonna be all right and I love
you and here's some tacos like I'm gonna
sit with you that's gonna be it and I
want to at some point there will be
meaning to make out of this she will
grow and we try to rush that process
this is gonna hurt it's gonna hurt for a
long time